the announcement of an agreement on the
basic lines of the preferred ftt ahead
of the european elections would also
send a strong signal to citizens the
large majority being in favor of this
project
moreover the rights of the
non-participating member states need to
be fully respected i cannot but repeat
that as it is clearly the case with the
commission's proposal the final design
of the tax and the enhanced cooperation
shall not hinder these rights
if um
european nations around this table want
to proceed with a
financial transaction tax
that
only has an impact in their
uh area in their economy than that is
their business um
our view has been that a
uh the financial transaction tax
uh that people have talked about is not
a tax on bankers
as
people present it as it's a tax on jobs
it's a tax on investment it's a tax on
people's pensions and on pensioners and
that's why the united kingdom does not
want to be part of it as do
a majority nor do a majority of
nations represented around this
table it's very difficult to see
the logic of this proposal you could
argue that there are european countries
that need tax increases and tax revenues
but then one should start with the tax
bases that are are least harmful for the
economy it is very hard to see
what is actually going on how this will
affect
both participating and unparticipating
countries
and that is of course
not satisfactory
this is highly relevant for any member
state
the two principles that the commission
are basing their proposal on
issuer and um
and and the other uh principle makes it
as relevant for us as it as it does for
the participating member states
obviously we need to be concerned about
uh putting down the base of a strong and
sustainable growth for the future for
all of our countries whilst
carrying out
courageous deep structural reforms but
also
we need to be
concerned to avoid what
caused our distress in 2000 and 2008
should not cause it again but i think
it's important also
within the enhanced cooperation to show
that europe is capable of moving forward
he is capable of turning ideas which
have been around for a long time after
all into acts
into decisions
i like transparent processes and
procedures
so
at least in the case of the spanish
delegation we are totally open to take
the considerations uh the implications
uh uh you know all the the remarks made
by non-participating countries because
we think that you know we do not want to
to to be uh to create an instrument that
is going to be harmful for for for
anybody what we want to do is to have a
rational tax
that puts order in the financials in the
in the financial markets
we have nothing decided
only we have agreed on a political
minimum position to go on and of course
we all agreed our colleague from malta
said yesterday again and again we need a
strong examination by legal service no
one want to offend any one of you
therefore the reaction has been a little
bit
maybe for the cameras to be very frank
the impression i get is that you have
found a very very small common ground
which is still very vague on the basis
for the tax when it will actually take
place on what products etc
uh but you have decided we must come out
with something before the elections that
that's fine
but please respect also the colleagues
we'd like to know a little more
to know what's going to happen some
colleagues will say we need to know more
because i want to know the negative
effects on my economy i would like to
know more that
maybe even there is a possibility for us
to join it's just the political point
that the willingness
to make the financial sector pay
is not in question the question is how
and how that can be handled when some uh
have the willingness to go forward with
enhanced corporation on this precise way
of taxing
which can be i think highly debated
whether it's more efficient i think not
than the way that we're doing it in
denmark and in some other countries